très bien mr jam ouch welcome je peux en
autriche du web comme ça m'est attribué
jim jarmusch is back there forme in the
eyes and billing holtz why can use my
english soeur et six au big for me to
two two accueil jim jarmusch bas 14
broken flowers with mr with them all
this movie coffee and cigarettes et je
crois je joue du piano à tulle juste
assis au piano
voilà tous ces films incroyables jim
jarmusch is back
de retour sur la croisette l'homme
l'eugénisme genius with the silver crazy
air with the genius inside the head and
even and said yeah lac david lynch tu
possèdes janus everybody everywhere want
your body you can use this crazy life is
life is so shops aux longues à damas et
jambon et les deux
jim jarmusch is back with dead like the
dead the dead the dead d'hendaye ces
magnifiques comme il est je des dents
dans les moeurs les morts ne meurent pas
les vivants oui c'est pour ça est ce
qu'il vaut mieux être mort que vivant
basse comme en aura pas je ne sais pas
mieux prefer to be dead like that c'est
déjà fait hors dooyoo want to be alive
est ce que c'est bien de you want to
play day de livewii puis cause à cannes
que dead aid you have to ride il va vous
sortir des vieux acteurs du sol et no
body one that bet5 youtube isère et puis
mon idole bill murray the man who spoke
ophrys bill murray et la haye soeur il
m'avait dit murray dans la vie oui
aujourd'hui marketing sûr vous aurez
tous de rencontrer quelqu'un quelqu'un
qu'on admirait quelqu'un qui vous a
enchanté on rêve tous de le rencontrer
lui non mr murray thank you for being
there are mon nom et au nom de toute
l'équipe du festival de cannes et à vous
tous de tout cacique de jim jarmusch
merci bonne projection à vous